alors qu'il a dit on s’est claquait des
portes à la gueule comme jamais il croit
que c'est je crois que c'est le mec avec
lequel je me suis le plus engueulé
c'est une
à toi c'est une productrice qui a dit ça
à propos d'un animateur Alexa la
roche-joubert à propos de deux Chavanes
effectivement ils avaient collaboré en
2003 pour Nice People et elle estime à
l'époque était au bord du gouffre il
faut quand même dire que hier en plus de
Chavanne avant-hier pardon était sur ce
plateau c'était un petit peu chaud mais
faut dire que dernièrement Victoria Sims
4 qui fait la roue de la fortune avec
lui a dit que ça s'est mal passé
Sandrine Quétier moyen Bennett il est
compliqué Alexa la roche-joubert c'est
quelqu'un avec qui on s'engueulait
c'était très chaud bokolini ils en sont
venus aux mains bref il y a un moment
je me tourne vers toi qui l'a connu mais
visiblement c'est compliqué et là la
pauvre est à Salamé elle elle sait pas
où elle va Christophe j'adore cette tête
j'ai bossé 6 ans avec lui donc oui
qu'est-ce que je peux dire
incroyable génial un animateur de folie
et à la fois ouais un mec complexe un
mec de colérique complexe qui change
la carrière déchiré avec lui vraiment on
a passé 6 ans parce qu'elle est moche
quand même donc c'est une grosse
histoire mais bon bah c'est quelqu'un
qui plus compliqué compliqué à gérer
alors Flavie papa
qu'elle était chroniqueuse de Chavannes
du produit une émission qui s'appelle
Sophie sans interdit TF1 le diffuse 40%
manager 5 cartons Mouge en veux 4 autres
et de savane qui détient c'est moi la
star ma chroniqueuse sera pas une star
appelle moujote et 10 si tu si je te
refais des primes c'est moi qui arrête
et du coup ils ont arrêté tous les
problèmes de clavier on n'est pas sur un
exemple de générosité à mort quand on a
eu quand on était appelé par TF1 97
parce qu'elle et moi pour faire il y a
pas photo à l'époque on était chez lui
et il nous a fait la gueule pendant
trois mois il nous a viré combien ça
coûte le soir même donc on a arrêté de
définitivement combien ça coûte au motif
qu'on avait une émission à nous sur TF1
ouais donc ça le faisait chier oui mais
tous ceux comme c'est le syndrome parce
que j'appelle le syndrome Claude
François Alain Chamfort il fait monter
des gens et quand les gens deviennent
ont une vraie notoriété il a un espèce
de de complexe qui fait qu'il se dit il
faut qu'ils arrêtent de grimper et donc
à ce moment-là il est il les flingue un
peu cela dit en interview c'est un
excellent client hein
c'est pas un truc il est pas cuisinier
nous tout ce qu'on dit et on l'a eu avec
cette semaine avec Jean-Michel c'est que
là hier soir il jouait oh là là moi je
veux plus de ça ça m'intéresse plus je
suis là dans un coin tu parles sur
l'ombre ce qui me dérange
un père et des productrices qui entre
guillemets crash voilà appel à pas non
plus elle a pas défoncé mais qui crache
un chapeau l'avait vu avec Bigard et sa
productrice on le voit avec sa
roche-joubert et de Chavannes tout ça un
peu dommage de salir la relation une
fois qu'on bosse plus ensemble d'autant
que tu es agent ou producteur de saison
tu bosses avec des artistes tu bosses
avec des gens qui ont des fêlures qui
sont compliquées
c'est juste un mec extraordinaire puis à
la fois c'est un mec pas toujours ça un
tour de table mais vraiment honnête mais
moi je dirais aussi l'animateur le plus
compliqué avec lequel des travailleurs
de Chavannes moi j'ai croisé enfin j'ai
bossé qu'avec Cyril et vous mais j'ai
croisé Ardisson il était pas très sympa
je tiens à mon poste quand même non mais
le plus compliqué
ah j'ai plus compliqué le plus compliqué
mais moi j'ai eu que toi et Benjamin
Castaldi après bah si je devais en
mettre les deux l'un à côté de l'autre
je pense qu'avec Benjamin c'était plus
dur parce que jamais elle est souvent
sur ses fiches il est souvent à regarder
ce qui se passe un peu perdu du coup il
s'intéresse un peu moins au chroniqueur
quand j'ai fait les saisons avec
Benjamin également j'étais à la place de
Kelly j'étais derrière et du coup
j'avais pas de l'AICE contact avec lui
donc du coup j'étais souvent oublié donc
c'était assez dérangeant pour moi mais
sinon je l'adore Sophie moi Dechavanne
j'ai pas eu une super expérience avec
lui non plus je dois dire non mais au
très honnêtement j'avais fait un casting
en fait on n'a jamais travaillé ensemble
à l'époque donc il avait sa boîte de
prod je sais pas s'il a toujours coyote
et je me demande si c'était pas pour
faire un truc avec toi d'ailleurs du
reste avec Laurent je me demande si
c'était pas pour être chroniqueuse sur
une de tes émissions il me semble et
pendant le casting donc il y avait
évidemment beaucoup de gens un tour de
table etc et je fais une faute de
syntaxe je dis pallier à bon voilà et on
dit pas tu allais ah on dit palier le
manque etc et en fait il me reprend
devant tout le monde et moi j'étais très
jeune à l'époque je vais avoir je sais
pas à 25 ans et en fait ça m'a
complètement désarçonné et je me suis
dit [ __ ] ce type
et ça m'a coupé
mon casting et je saoule c'est dommage
que le talent toi
plus de journalistes que d'animateur
mais celui dans le système est compliqué
à intégrer c'est deniso moi j'ai fait la
première année du Grand Journal c'est
vrai qu'il était beaucoup avec ben c'est
son équipe et que quand on est à
l'extérieur on sait jamais trop ce qu'il
pense que je l'aimais bien mais c'est
contraignante moi je vais encore parler
de Christophe Dechavanne parce qu'il y a
une époque mon métier c'était d'aller
dans les soirées à la rencontre des
personnalités particulièrement des gens
de télé et l'un des plus compliqués que
j'ai croisé c'est Christophe Dechavanne
qui a été particulièrement désagréable
voire même un peu agressif donc j'en
garde pas un très bon saut et je pousse
anecdote hier mais je suis désolé parce
que ça m'a marqué après elle est assez
des photos merde l'humoriste que j'adore
j'ai une Cadière aussi enlever son micro
qui est passé là là et qui est sorti là
mais je crois que tu n'aimait même pas
serré la même série il est parti faire
la même personne
et pourtant c'est mon idole
le plus compliqué avec toi Jean-Michel
[Rires]
moi j'ai côtoyé Benjamin Castaldi Cyril
Hanouna et Matthieu Delormeau et sans
surprise Matthieu Delormeau
mais quand il y a un nom comme ça qui
revient tout le temps et qu'on le sait
parce que c'est quand même de notoriété
publique on va pas se mentir on est dans
un petit milieu tout le monde sait tout
sur tout le monde moi ça me fascine
toujours et ça m'étonne qu'on le
rappelle en fait
[Musique]
tes petites habitudes à toi ton petit
massage pendant le maquillage
ah ben moi j'ai toujours dit je suis
d'accord avec Cyril la condamnation
c'est le cancer de la télé je te le dis
je te le dis jamais cru sauf quand c'est
toujours mais mais mais voilà mais c'est
vrai que nous ça avait été un peu chaud
un moment oh là là on rencontre à Patou
ça sera pour la semaine d'après c'était
la saison encore une cicatrice euh
Jean-Mi Leon citron cabane
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais ta connaissance tu as connu dans
des trône bien sûr pourquoi j'aurais pas
connu et ben d'accord ben c'est pas
travailler avec lui je travaille pas
ouais merci Jean-Michel